eugénie pedneault va terminer dans deux
semaines son service civique
c'était une viande en histoire et
communication à mener à terme son
contrat de neuf mois à raison de 24
heures par semaine ça a été une
expérience très enrichissante pour moi
une première expérience professionnelle
en fait ça m'a fait découvrir le monde
associatif le bénévolat
voilà la réalité aussi enfin sur le
terrain réalité sociale en fait avant
d'être volontaire génie a débuté comme
bénévole à la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines
elle vient épauler les 15 autres
bénévoles de l'épicerie sociale basée à
trappes
ici il y a à faire près de 1400 familles
aidées en 2012 sont les bénévoles on ne
rêve le pays sera encore plus divisés
et cabossé qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui en
visite ce lundi matin le ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire est donc
venu se rendre compte du travail
quotidien et plus largement apporté son
soutien aux associations caritatives
la loi de finances votée à la fin de
l'année devrait prévoir une mesure pour
réduire les impositions sur salaire nous
réfléchissons à une mesure qui
permettent d'aligner le niveau des
impôts payés par ces associations sur
celui des grandes entreprises privées
qui allons bénéficier du crédit d'impôt
et qui ainsi ont pu économiser des
centaines de milliers d'euros et comme
les associations ne payent pas d'impôt
sur les sociétés mais de la taxe sur les
salaires
elle réclame pour les gros en tout cas
une mesure d'équivalence une mesure qui
si elle est actée devrait donner plus
d'air aux associations caritatives et
elles en ont bien besoin en cette
période de crise où les demandes de
soutien affluent sur le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines
une autre problématique est apparue
depuis l'été dernier l'augmentation du
nombre de réfugiés de l'est et d'afrique
ils sont aujourd'hui entre 200 et 300
aider directement par la croix rouge
tout ce qu'on fait en direct on est aidé
par personne donc là c'est nous qui
supportant la totalité des dépenses et
ça pour une première année depuis que je
suis président nous terminons l'année
plutôt en déficit qu'autre chose
l'épicerie sociale de trappes est
ouverte dorénavant à raison de cinq demi
journées par semaine